rivers full of fish with overflowing
banks and lots of room for floods there
can't be a better habitat for the fish
otter places like this still exists in
the southern Carpathian Mountains in
Romania a region especially popular for
fly-fishing Oh video me hoots has been
fishing here for brook trout and
European grayling since his childhood or
rather he used to that's because further
downstream the riverbed has changed a
lot a hydropower plant has reduced water
levels the remaining water in the
riverbed warms up too quickly and it's
depleted of oxygen thereby suffocating
the fish
now madam our deck hit just five percent
of the original water levels remain a
thing with Jessica I just look at some
in 2010 the plant was simply
barbarically set up here in the midst of
nature puttin on al domi is AJ here
where the riverbed is quite narrow
squeezed together while being with heavy
machines have destroyed everything these
tools are the intervention with Elijah
Lord grayleigh and it's all promoted by
the government right in the middle of a
European wildlife sanctuary that belongs
to the network natura 2000 turbines have
been installed in long pipes in the
river to produce energy it actually is
an eco-friendly model but not when seven
such facilities are built on a single
river
it's the steep location of the wilds
dreams here that makes the remote region
especially lucrative for investors as a
result of the construction boom local
residents have to live with the fact
that even the old water sources for
their livestock have dried up resin
completed a dinner out or eat that she
took when you look at the obvious link
between the authorities and private
investors you have to ask whether this
is a case of carelessness bad intentions
or worse what is the few what about any
corruption attack editha saw my toe they
caught up to you the environment
ministry in Bucharest however denies the
allegations it says it's proud of its
push for renewables and insists all the
permits in southern Carpathia were
approved legally we stuck to the law we
even sent a report to the EU in which
the Technical University for
construction concluded there would be no
significant impact on the environment
got it aquastar thought the positive we
constantly monitor these investments and
regions and I can confirm there are no
effects on the environment the normal
said about when you [ __ ] significant so
the subsidies and construction continued
unabated the government and private
investors point to the clean energy
generated and say other environmental
factors are responsible for the decline
of fish stocks experts say 550 small
hydropower plants have been built or
planned in just two years mainly in the
South Carpathian region if you take a
close look at romania's energy supply
you can see that the goals for renewable
energy have already been achieved
Romania has long been producing more
green energy than needed but we don't
have the capacity to export electricity
at the moment there are no economic
reasons for such investments because
rivers that have so far been untouched
are precisely the ones being destroyed
exactly totally rude Caryn phenomenal
was affecting the government has now
promised to review its plans even though
a study has already identified four
thousand new potential sites for small
hydropower plants she start somewhere in
this I have to ask are we the fishermen
the Romanians to blame for allowing this
to happen I saw something play
everything is happening under the noses
of the authorities here I'll still
without with what they simply don't want
to stop this development why didn't you
should we the citizens do something
against it oh video me hoots wants other
Brooks and streams to be spared the same
fate in the heart of Europe's last
remaining wilderness
you